I'm here with the very funny Ricky
Gervais who I just learned was once upon
a time also a budding rock star okay so
can you explain this photo to me all I
can say is I was 20 years old look at
that
I think when you look like a friggin
rock star and people say what happened
I'll tell you what happened
Barin pizza that's what happened attack
me they're like what has she been doing
well obviously eating and not working
out I like rocket scientist to figure
out someone just maybe has like living
is the question how did you get started
in music I didn't know that like is that
your first love
I guess so I love science and nature and
then maybe 30 40 not going to music and
then when I was a teenager with David
Bowie and then I went to university and
I did sciences I've got it just
university studies Sciences but then I
realize no I want to join a band I've
come to university tutorial and and I
changed the philosophy which was a lot
less hours a week than science I started
a band and we got signed and it was over
as quick as it's died my rock career was
one year one year long hey that's longer
than some people get so subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going